I assure you brother The Sun will shine
on us again your optimism is misplaced
has gone well for one thing I'm north
Asgardian and for another we have a home
and it's very exciting and I found it
quite this is odd thing to say but I
found it quite touching because I
remember I remember when I was cast as
Loki for the very first time almost 10
years ago and Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios called me into his
office to congrat to say congratulations
and then one of the first things servers
let me talk to you about Avengers and I
thought I just been cast in Thor right
and he's told me the dream he had to to
build to build this a fleet of films
this Marvel Cinematic Universe that was
culminating in Avengers and suddenly the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is has
expanded to such an extraordinary size
that it can you know encompass and
encapsulate so many different characters
who people have taken to their hearts
and and followed and loved and I feel so
lucky to be a part of it
so that's why I found it exciting
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of Loki and Avengers to talk about
during Marvel phase four they just
confirmed a whole bunch of details about
the Loki TV series and we have a little
teaser plot synopsis that I'll breakdown
there's a new brand of that Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Loki moment on the video so if you have
no idea what's going on Tom Hiddleston
is coming back to play Loki in an
ongoing Marvel TV series for the Disney
Plus streaming service it's gonna be one
of many
Avengers spin-off TV series with the MCU
actor so this isn't like somebody else
that they're gonna cast as Loki this is
Tom Hiddleston playing his character in
brand new episodes that'll probably be
premiering later this year really
important stuff first what is it about
what are they actually gonna be doing
because Loki supposedly died during
infinity war so how they gonna address
of interest endgame
what's going on during the movies right
now it'll make a little more sense when
I explain what the plot actually is so
what they're saying is if there's a show
will follow Loki as he pops up
throughout human history is an unlikely
influencer of historical events so think
about real life events and big events in
the MC use history speaking I just might
wish company at least no less when I
kill you in this form very well perhaps
you prefer one of your new companions
given that you seem to like them so much
oh this is much better
Oh costumes a bit much so title the
confidence they can feel the righteous
is surging hey wanna have a rousing
discussion about truth honor patriotism
the bigger question I think those is
when does it actually take place when it
picks up is this gonna be a version of
Loki from before Thanos kills him in
Avengers infinity war or after Avengers
endgame which we know Tom Hiddleston's
Loki is going to guest star during but
it's gonna be an earlier version of Loki
from the events of the Battle of New
York so even though Loki is back in
Avengers endgame it's not this version
of Loki coming back to life but it's
important to note that we don't know if
they're going to be multiple versions of
Loki showing up during Avengers endgame
because it's so big and it's still wide
open to speculation so there is a chance
that a post Thanos version of Loki could
also show up in some form during the
movie I know there's a lot of Loki
truthers out there that want to believe
that he faked his death Tom Hiddleston
has said that he thinks that Loki died
sacrificing himself in a final act of
redemption which would imply that he's
pretty dead after this moment and if you
look at all the differences in the
earlier versions of the infinity war
script in the final script they made it
pretty clear that the Russos and the
screenwriters intended for him to die in
this moment so if a post Thanos version
of Loki comes back during endgame going
into phase four it would have to be in
the form of a vision tooth or the same
way that Odin speaks to Thor from Faja
from beyond death which loki is also
capable of doing and has done many times
in the comics so no big surprise there
that he's not bound by space-time or
death it just doesn't work exactly the
way that you might think it does the
thing about the Loki character is that
they have really clever ways of bending
traditional rules that other regular
characters are bound by the easiest way
hands down to just address all these
issues is to show a younger version of
the character just visiting earth for
purposes of mischief mischief managed
throughout the years leading up to the
events of the first Thor film in all the
other MCU films any of the timeline that
he's been alive for in present day so
just because it might be a younger
version of the character doesn't mean
that he couldn't also hop around during
the timeline of the phase 1 phase 2 in
phase 3 movies up to the events of
infinity war where this Loki wound up
dying that is how you get your Chris
Hemsworth Thor cameos he can play any
number of younger versions of himself
he's 1500 years old in present day so
presumably they'll do some much younger
stuff and show multiple versions of the
character including Tom Hiddleston like
you have kin Loki you have female Loki
he's a shapeshifter so they'll probably
gonna have a lot of fun with the people
that he impersonates one time we were
children he transformed himself into a
snake and he knows that all snakes so I
went to pick up the snake to admire it
and he transformed back into himself and
he was like yeah it's me he stopped me
you can also get your Odin and your
frigate cameos I would argue that Frigga
is probably a more important character
for his upbringing if they're gonna do a
very young version of the character like
you show him learning magic and then
just using it to cause mischief on
planet earth but because they're using
all the movie actors in these Kevin
Feige Avengers TV series and they are
Kevin Feige series he's personally
making them himself with other show
runners and producers in a way that he
does not with the regular Marvel TV
shows like agents of shield that means
that they have access to all the movie
actors that you're seeing in Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame but if
for some reason they have a problem and
they're not able to get Robert Downey
jr. or Chris Evans for instance or the
other Avengers to guest star in episodes
you can do younger versions of those
characters as Loki pops up during
history you have a teenage version of
Tony Stark popping up or you see Loki
show up during World War two and mess
with something while Captain America is
fighting Reds
because Loki would be very interested in
the tesseract he was hidden in that
village in Norway when the Red Skull
found it
what a coincidence that in Avengers
endgame Thor is building new Asgard in
Norway so there a lot of places that
Odin Thor and Loki visited on planet
earth through the eons growing up now
remember Thor's about 1500 years old and
present-day
Loki is a little bit younger than that
Odin is the only one that's way way
older than that in fact speaking of the
tesseract because that's such a big
thing in Loki's history in the MCU going
back to the first Avengers film there's
an interesting story about how the
tesseract wound up in that Norway
village where Red Skull found it in the
cosmic sense after the tesseract was
created
Odin found that put it in his vault for
safekeeping
then in ancient times for some reason he
took it to Planet Earth and for unknown
reasons left it there that's when it
wound up in that village in Norway and
had been there ever since hidden in that
giant wall carving of the world tree
another really good example of a huge
real-world historical event that they
inserted Thor into in the comics is
isn't recontextualizing the story of
Beowulf to say that it was based on a
real thing that Thor did in the history
of this Norse region it was a Thor
versus Grendel story but in reality the
Grendel that he was fighting was the
primal symbiote aka the necro sword made
by the god of the symbiotes no
interdimensional ruler of the void from
before the Celestials were created in
the first firmament so was just a funny
way to say that real-world things that
we have like the poem of Beowulf is
actually inspired by Thor so just
imagine Loki popping up during different
events inspiring major things that
happen during the MC use history so in
that way it doesn't trample on
pre-existing canon like all the things
that you saw happen in history
everything you know about the characters
still happened it's just one of those
zoom and enhance situations where like
you look in the background of shots in
saying oh loki was here just nudging the
characters a little bit so say Captain
America still defeats the Red Skull
during World War two who then gets
transported to for Mir by the space
stone but maybe Loki nudged some of the
players at times in an attempt at
mischief but also a really big tie back
to Loki in the first Avengers movie the
tesseract very important for his
character a young Howard Stark worked on
the tesseract after they found it Loki
could also show up during that and mess
Howard Stark a little and we see the
writers winking and moments between a
younger teenage Tony Stark and Loki
without him realizing who he's seeing so
like an evil quantum leap with Loki
jumping into different people's bodies
because he's sort of shape-shifting and
clamoring himself to make himself look
like other people without literally
traveling through time because he's just
popping up as he grows up because he's
so long-lived
the really important details like I said
though the expected release date it
sounds like it's going to be at the end
of this year when they launched the
Disney Plus streaming service I think
they're trying to launch the service
with a bunch of their original shows one
of those being the Loki series the other
being the Scarlet Witch envision TV
series that could be anytime between
October and November we'll probably get
the first trailer comic-con this summer
the last report I saw said it was going
to be eight to ten episodes for all the
different series so remember there's the
Loki series there's a Scarlet Witch in
vision series there's also a Winter
Soldier and Falcon series they'll all be
eight to ten episodes in however many
seasons they wind up going I think just
depends on how successful they are and
the actors availability but they haven't
announced any hirings for that Winter
Soldier TV series so I don't think that
that one's gonna premiere till next year
sometime in the spring but let me know
in the comments what do you guys think
about this which events do you actually
want Loki to show up for big MCU
historical events so it could be stuff
during present day when he was alive
during phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 it could
be back during the 80s it could be the
obvious real-world historical events
that aren't necessarily just MCU
historical events but I think they're
gonna try and maintain a certain canon
with the MCU films so what'll happen is
is we get any more news about it I will
totally do a new video and obviously
it's gonna be a little while before we
see footage but there'll be new Avengers
endgame stuff happening in a couple
weeks when Captain Marvel drops I've
also got new Captain Marvel stuff
supposed to click here for my brand new
Avengers and game trailer in post
credits scene video and click here to
watch a Ben Affleck explained why he
quit being Batman before his contract
was up thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]